más de 20 personas han muerto a causa de
las fuertes lluvias en venezuela el
municipio más afectado es sucre del
estado de mérida en el noroeste del país
tal como lo explicó el protector de la
región jason guzmán probablemente hay
que informarle al presidente que hemos
tenido ayer cuando le pase a la
empezamos el informe teníamos un reporte
de 15 personas fallecidas s este número
creció durante el día de hoy ha llegado
a un número de 20 personas fallecidas
hoy nos reportaron personas fallecidas
en el sector kirk ahora en el municipio
sucre
guzmán afirmó que los daños son muy
considerables y no dio más detalles
también señaló que continúan con las
labores de rescate y levantamiento de
escombros pero no es el único estado ha
afectado los deslaves también están
impactando en apure bolívar yaracuy y
zulia de hecho el presidente nicolás
maduro firmó un decreto de emergencia
por 90 días para todos estos estados
actualmente estoy aprobando los recursos
suficientes innecesario
en bolívares en cripto moneda y en
divisas convertibles todos los recursos
que le haga falta a mérida para que
ustedes actúen con la mayor contundencia
es resultado desde lunes de esta semana
ha habido deslizamientos en la sierra
ubicada a orillas del desbordado río
mocotíes en el estado de mérida y el
instituto nacional de metereología e
hidrología advirtió que se espera que
las lluvias continúen en los próximos
días